the Chess Club and scholastic Center of  st. Louis is an educational organization  committed to promoting the game of chess  both locally and nationally with the  specific focus on bringing the benefits  of chess to st. Louis area school  children located in the historic Central  West End the Chess Club is a three level  state-of-the-art Community Center  featuring classrooms a library and a  world-class tournament playing hall the  club is widely recognized as the premier  chess facility in the nation and one of  the best in the world it plays host to  the u.s. championship US Women's  Championship and the u.s. Junior closed  championship the club also hosts the  Sinquefield cup the strongest chess  tournament held on US soil and one of  the strongest tournaments in the world  for more information about the Chess  Club and scholastic Center of st. Louis  please visit us at st. Louis chess club  org